other few would laugh at me in fact all
my friends say we worry about you Dilys
you know and they even kept up this
weekend somebody said oh now be careful
I think that's ridiculous what a better
way to die having fun I am a world
record holder for being the oldest woman
skydiver in the world I think is there's
only one way it's down so even if I got
slight absent-mindedness I'll be alright
I don't worry that my carpets is rather
threadbare and old as long as I was guy
diving but I do get scared
I used to be so scared that I would
drive the car up to the the drop zone
and think I could go back I don't have
to stay here but I knew if I went away
I'd never come back again
so the the the ecstasy was more than the
fear the first time I jumped up an
aeroplane I thought I was gonna die and
as I fell I thought what a mistake this
is death I just remember it now and then
the next second I thought ah I'm flying
skydiving gives you the most intense
wonderful feeling I mean people come
down from the sand and jump and they all
say it's better than sex I will take
that the way you like it
but it is
I think sometimes we get pulled out by
fear we get pulled down by necessity of
work and it's a mistake but having done
skydive I learned courage I learned to
go and that has been the biggest turning
point in my life and I think the courage
has helped me to run a charity which
from scratch is very difficult I they
say most charities fail after three
years and I knew that I had a program
that affected for the good
they've profoundly disabled people made
them really much happier and that
thrills me I believe we all have a
purpose in life and I believe that
extras is my purpose
I don't have much time to think about
the past I'm so busy in the present and
just going into the future that the past
recedes and I am enjoying so much these
days remembering the past remembering
even the difficult times but seeing how
they all fell into a pattern which now
I'm glad of you are a bird for 50
seconds and imagine you can go 240 miles
an hour you can do a barrel roll you can
flick you can move here you can move
there you can join up with people it is
unbelievably wonderful I won't stop till
I know it's not safe
but for now I'm safe and I can do it and
I will do it for as long as I can
you